bigard alors même qu'on va maintenant
faire un petit jeu avec un petit jeu
très simple c'est le contrôle alors le
jeu le jeu de la vraie vérité la lumière
s'il vous plaît commence dès que vous
arrivez en est à annoncer maintenant le
cas suspect ou pas non c'est après le
quitus qui s'est juste après alors le
jeu de la vraie vérité non vous
connaissez le principe patrick sébastien
le jeu de la priorité c'est par exemple
pour nous il est deux heures du matin on
était copains d'un peu torché et on dit
maintenant on va se dire la vraie vérité
on va tout le temps dire des salaires
ont les salaires mais on peut donner
salaire médian est devenu les salaires
je passe alors il n'y a pas de joker
quoniou bon donc chacun peut poser les
questions qui veut à qui il veut je les
questions au genre alors lui tu
commences tu commences tu poses à qui tu
veux n'importe quelle question du moment
qu'elle lui fait dire la vraie vérité
obligé de répondre été obligé de
répondre à court terme s'élevait à kde
l'oreille tu m'aimes je vais je vais
très désagréable
non je vais très agréable ça ne s'est
pas du tout mon genre de mec quoi bon ça
va cogner
est ce que vous aimez son humour ah oui
beaucoup et j'aime bien j'aime bien ce
qu'ils jugent bon papa tous les nomme
pas lui tout sur tout et sur tous les
outils les trous noirs là c'est reparti
il faut dire qu'elle était le fait rire
linder vie de poser une question à l'un
d'entre eux dit legends est parti faire
quoi cela va encore qu'est-ce que vous
avez une question oppose je comprends
pas regardez on a regardé le débat c'est
intéressant
ils sont les terres pipi on s'est auto
touchés par ce que je voulais c'est ce
que tu fais ça c'est vraiment bien ces
mutations de patrick son book cad
non car olivier houël charlie lui voilà
cet argent vient souvent la confusion
psystar nouvelles questions à patrick
sébastien moi et que j'ai envie depuis
très très longtemps puis chez touquet et
sculpté de la famille à belle et
sébastien
bizarrement je veux dire pourquoi dans
cette copa ce quelqu'un quand mon fils
aîné c'était pile dans l'époque de belle
et sébastien
je les appelais sébastien à cause du
feuilleton et quand il a fallu que je
choisis ce nombre j'ai planté lance en
pis voilà au dessus de la famille
messieurs merci d'autres questions l'on
voit la question qu'on a tous envie de
poser linda clitoridienne vaginale merci
dû l'enlever de la mort
je suis contente j'ai des élèves dans
melinda vos réponses tout cas les guides
la lituanie mais pour d'avoir parié sa
dépouille du mec
wa quels rapports avec des gens pleurent
franchement mais franchement franchement
noir comme
chergui comme charles mignon mais avec
des gens de couleurs métissées une
couleur on y va
c'est ça principaux visés beaumont pour
allumer la lumière mesdames messieurs
merci à tous bon maintenant on va